And so, I asked our teacher
after this whole exercise,
how do you actually go about
changing the world?
Like, tactically speaking,
what are ways to embody that message?
And he told me,
"Ben, one of the best ways
to change the world
is to be an entrepreneur."
Ben Casnocha, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
I am so thankful to have you here.
Thank you for being so generous
with your time.
Thanks for having me, Michael.
It's a pleasure to have you.
We have way too much to talk about.
I want to just run forward.
And considering everything
that you've done,
which is incredible,
I'd love to hear about Village Global,
I'd love to hear about your work
with Reid Hoffman
and the two New York Times best sellers
that you wrote and the different insights
that you've gained into helping
young entrepreneurs on their journey.
The majority of the audience
for this show
is young entrepreneurs like myself,
just starting their journey.
And I think that going back and relieving
some of these lessons that you
so thoughtfully highlight
in a lot of your writing,
that will just be incredible.
So Ben, how about you take me down
memory lane, just walk me through
some of the really cool things
that you've gotten to take a part of.
And we'll touch on some lessons
here and there from there.
And, I'll of course, interrupt
when I'm especially curious.
When I was 12 years old,
I took a class in school
that was a computer repair class.
And so, we learned how to fix and repair
Macintosh computers
as an elective course at my school.
And it was designed, of course,
to allow the school to use us
as child labor to repair all the
school computers when they broke.
But I learned a lot about
how to fix computers
in a really helpful class.
And at the end of the semester,
we had a final exam.
But the final exam was very different
than any other exam I've taken.
The teacher announced that
all we would have to do
to get an A plus on the exam
is memorize and recite a poem
back to him perfectly.
And if we could do that successfully,
he would give us
an A plus in the class.
So, the exam would have nothing to do
with all of the material
we've studied in the class.
All we would have to do is recite a poem.
And so, 24 hours before the class,
he distributes the poem
and it actually turns out
not to be a literary poem,
but rather the text transcription
of Apple computer's
"Think Different"
television advertisement
which ran in the late 1980s,
and early 1990s.
If you haven't seen the ad,
you can go on YouTube and search
for Apple Computer "Think Different",
and you can see the ad for yourself.
But I was forced to memorize that ad
when I was 12 years old
and recite it back to him perfectly.
And maybe I'll share with you now,
just for folks who don't know
how it goes.
It's short.
The advertisement says,
"Here's to the crazy ones,
the misfits, the rebels,
the round pegs in the square holes,
the ones who see things differently.
They're not fond of rules
and they have no respect
for the status quo.
You can quote them,
disagree with them,
glorify or vilify them.
But about the only thing you can't do
is ignore them because they change things
and they push the human race forward.
And while some may see them
as the crazy ones, we see genius.
Because the people
who are crazy enough
to think they can change the world
are the ones who do."
And so, at a really young age,
I was reciting this message back to him.
Yeah, it was life changing.
And so, I asked our teacher
after this whole exercise,
how do you actually
go about changing the world?
Like, tactically speaking,
what are ways to embody that message?
And he told me,
"Ben one of the best ways
to change the world
is to be an entrepreneur,
is to see opportunity
where other people see challenge,
to not just complain about problems
in the world,
but try to solve those problems."
And he said,
"The next time you experience
frustration in your life,
ask yourself whether
you could solve that frustration for you
and everyone else
who has that frustration and maybe
make some money while doing it."
And up until that point in my life,
I had really not thought of myself
as an entrepreneur.
I didn't know much
about entrepreneurship,
but he really inspired me to think
and apply that lens to the world
to see problem as opportunity.
And so, I started my first company
when I was 14 years old,
and I've never looked back.
Seeing every problems an opportunity.
I love that.
I've been thinking that,
I recall when I was in the IDF
and I was leading a team there
and we're constantly faced with problems,
and especially
in a very bureaucratic area.
A lot of the times these problems
surrounded the lack of funding
and the lack of our ability
to get new talent coming in.
We had what we had
and a lot of times
they look up to me and say,
"Michael, we have a problem."
And I kept thinking
we have an opportunity for a solution.
And I just love
that embodiment and mindset.
So, walk me through
some of the other experiences
that you've had
and how have you used that mindset
to get excited about these problems
that you're facing?
Well, the first bias that I had
about the mindset was that
it was a Silicon Valley only idea.
I was living and growing up
in San Francisco, actually at that time.
And so as I learned more
about entrepreneurship, I assumed
that what entrepreneurship meant
was starting a technology business
in Silicon Valley
because that's what everyone else
was doing around me.
And it wasn't until
I really started traveling
and I left the US for the first time
and traveled around
meeting with different people
who I'd met online,
who had been following
some of my writing,
that I realized that entrepreneurship
was actually global.
That there are people
all around the world with that mindset.
And there are people creating
all different types of businesses
all around the world.
You didn't need to be in San Francisco.
You actually also don't need
to be starting a tech business.
There are lots of different types
of businesses to start
and a lot of problems
to solve in the world.
And so, a really formative experience
for me after the Mac,
after my teacher forced me to memorize
the Apple advertisement,
was leaving America for the first time
when I was
maybe 18 years old
and spending four or five months
in Asia, in Europe and Latin America
and some in the Middle East, and just
meeting all these different people
who were inspiring me
with their own entrepreneurial energy.
And that really taught me about
entrepreneurship is a global idea,
and that it's a life idea
more than a business one.
It's a mindset that you apply
to your life and to any industry.
You don't just have to be
starting an Internet company.
I just love that. Obviously.
Coming from Israel,
my grandparents came
on the boats into a Kibbutz
and that whole
entrepreneurial journey there,
they're telling me,
"Michael, you know,
you think you're an entrepreneur,
you go to Silicon Valley
with all your VC friends,
and you form startups?"
"No. The real entrepreneurship story
is how this world is formed
and how we built railroads
and how we invented agriculture
in the middle of the desert."
I mean, these are the real.
And so, I couldn't agree more.
And talk to me a little bit about
Village Global
because it's a phenomenal,
phenomenal idea.
It's not just another
venture capital fund.
You're building this incredible community
of global thinkers and global leaders.
Probably if I just started
reciting the names,
the jaws are going to drop
of people that are involved.
And I have some great friends
that are part of this network.
Tell me a little bit about
what you've built
and what was the motivation
behind building this
hundred million dollar
venture capital fund?
Yeah, a few years ago,
my partners and I founded Village Global
to be an entirely new
sort of venture capital firm.
And we believe that the nature
of entrepreneurship was changing.
And so, we needed to build
a venture platform
that would change with it,
that would adapt to this new world
of entrepreneurship
in the new world of work.
Some of the ways that entrepreneurship
have changed include this global point
that we've been talking about,
which is there are great talent
all around the world.
It's cheaper and easier
to start a company than ever before.
And increasingly,
software is transforming
all different types of industries.
And so, it's a much more diverse
set of businesses today that VC's
ought to invest in rather than just
traditional software companies.
And so, we built Village with the idea
of being a network driven venture firm
that could invest around the world
in all different types of
IT-enabled businesses.
One of the things
that makes Village unique is
we believe that today's
young entrepreneurs derive a great deal
of inspiration from their iconic heroes
in the industry,
people like Mark Zuckerberg,
people like Bill Gates,
Jeff Bezos and other folks like that.
And so, we spent a long time
raising our fund from those people.
So, those people
are the investors in Village.
And then we take their personal capital
and we in turn invest it in the smartest
entrepreneurs that we can find.
So as to sort of bridge the generations
between today's young entrepreneurs
and the luminaries who back Village.
So, just to iterate
this notion that you're taking people
like Mark Zuckerberg, Jeff Bezos,
Bill Gates and the likes,
literally investing their personal funds
into a venture capital fund
that whose mission it is to invest
globally in IT solutions that are really
breakthrough and the smartest people.
How do you go about
fulfilling that mission?
First of all, it sounds like
it's a lot of responsibility.
It sounds like a very scary
responsibility to take.
But I'm sure that it's
incredibly exciting.
But how do you actually go ahead
and deploy that strategy
and find those best people
around the world?
We have a unique network model
for discovering the best talent
around the world.
So, most venture capital firms
historically have operated
where there is a handful
of general partners
who sit in an office,
usually in Menlo Park, California,
or some other ecosystem, Tel Aviv,
different places around the world
where there are a lot of VCs.
But the partners really act
as if they are masters of the universe,
as if they know all the people who matter
and they expect founders
to parade into their office
and pitch their business.
But we have a different approach.
We leverage a network
of founders themselves, angel investors,
professors, ecosystem leaders,
and we empower those people
with our capital to go back
their smartest friends.
And so it's a bit more
of a decentralized effort
to source and select
the smartest founders we can.
And by using a network,
we're able to find
really amazing entrepreneurs
in hidden and undiscovered places.
Wow, what do you get most excited about?
Because you're coming from
the very entrepreneurial background,
you've built several companies,
companies that have made
a huge impact back then.
And I believe that some of the companies
that you've built, their technology still
being deployed today, one of which
is used by hundreds of local governments.
So, you've made a huge impact
as an entrepreneur yourself,
and now you are making huge impact
as a venture capital investor.
What really makes you excited
about what you're doing?
I think the thing that's really exciting
about our work is being the first
to believe in a founder.
So, we are often at Village,
we're often investing
in pre-seed and seed stage rounds
or a formation stage rounds
where we're the first person
to commit to the first firm,
to commit to a founder.
And so, we really feel like
we are increasing
the total entrepreneurship in the world.
There's a lot of capital
that will pile in
to late stage venture rounds
where they're already,
Stride, for example,
apparently is raising a new round
of financing
at a hundred billion dollar valuation.
That's awesome.
Stride had a huge impact.
But it's more fulfilling for me to think
that we could be the first to invest
in Stride at the
two million dollar valuation
rather than the
hundred billion dollar valuation,
because that's what it means
to bet on the underdogs.
That's what it means to take a risk.
That's what it means
to believe when others do not.
And I think there's something
very satisfying about having that
sort of contrarian view and then
seeing all these other investors
follow us at later stages.
100%.
I took a fascinating class
with Ann from Floodgate at Stanford,
a venture capital class.
And one of the things
that we talked about
was the different investment stages.
I have the privilege of doing
the due diligence in the fund called
the J-Ventures in very early stage.
And one of the key differences
that I was always taught was that
if you're investing early stage,
your due diligence
is really about the people.
It's about their backgrounds,
about their personality
and their perseverance.
Their due diligence on later stages
is a lot also
about the spreadsheets,
about the finances,
about you believing in the business model
moving forward.
So, I can definitely see the excitement
that you bring towards this.
Ben, take me back a little bit
to your entrepreneurial journey.
Obviously you're doing
incredible stuff now
with Village Global,
but that's just the sliver
about your humungous experience.
Talk to me about the different ventures
that you've formed and the two books
that you've written with Reid Hoffman.
Sure.
Well, I was rolling back the clock
to that class that I took where I
memorized the Apple advertisement
and then the global trip I took
that opened my eyes
to global entrepreneurship.
I spent several years
founding and running
an enterprise software company
that sold CRM software
to local governments.
And I really enjoyed that experience.
And that business
continues today to serve
a whole bunch of customers in the US.
I took a few years break
from entrepreneurship
and focused on writing,
and those are the books you mentioned.
So, I co-authored a book called,
The Start‑up of You,
which is a career strategy guide
on how to apply entrepreneurial
insights to your own life.
And then I co-authored a book called
The Alliance,
which is about how companies
can attract entrepreneurial talent
into their organizations.
Both are bestsellers,
but that's irrelevant, of course.
Well, that we were really lucky
that both books found
an engaged audience.
And both topics are really interesting,
I think.
And I learned a lot.
Writing forces you to
clarify your thinking.
And so to really flash out my views
and to get to know my co-author,
Reid Hoffman, which started LinkedIn
in both of those books,
that was a really tremendous privilege.
And so, I've been going back and forth
in my life between writing
and entrepreneurship.
These days, I'm 100% focused
on Village Global
and entrepreneurship and venture capital.
But I suspect in the future I'll go back
to writing books at some point
and hopefully go back and forth because
you can have a different
sort of impact writing books.
For me, my drug of choice is impact,
so entrepreneurship's certainly one way.
But you can also influence
the way people think,
and books and articles
are a way of doing that for me.
Right.
All this back and forth,
going from being an entrepreneur
to being a writer,
spending time at the LinkedIn
and Greylock offices, venture capital,
suspecting to link back,
talk to me about this whole mindset
of moving around and experiencing
and really mastering and harnessing
this different skill sets
as a lifelong entrepreneur.
I think some of us live lives that are
unplanned and serendipitous
and involve lots of zigging and zagging.
And that's certainly been my life.
I've never had a grand master plan.
Every year brings its own share
of surprises and opportunities.
Of course, the year 2020
is a great example of this.
Whatever plan people may have laid
in January has almost certainly
been disrupted by the pandemic.
And so, I'm a huge believer
in staying adaptive,
staying flexible and being
opportunistic as things arise.
And for me,
sort of my blessing and my curse is
that I have a lot of different interests.
And so, there are a lot of things
I want to do in this world that are
somewhat unrelated to each other.
And so, for me,
venture capital is an interesting path
because it does actually
involve a lot of diversity.
There are a lot of different
types of businesses.
We invest in a lot of different
sorts of challenges,
and that's satisfying.
By contrast, you know,
when you start a company requires
a lot of focus on just that company
for a very long period of time.
And there are advantages to that.
I actually think you can have
the most impact in the world
by starting the business
much more than a VC can.
But the tradeoff is
you're really thinking
about that one industry,
that one product area for potentially
10 to 12, 15, 20 years of your life.
And so for me, my own
zigging and zagging in life
has been an attempt to satisfy
a diverse set of interests.
Going back all the way to being
12 years old and reciting
the great poem, but then,
you know, a lot of the people that are
hopefully watching this
are young entrepreneurs,
whether they're from Stanford
and any other college in the US,
from Tel Aviv.
And it's scary.
You know, it feels like a constant race.
There's a lot of pressure
going on that you have to raise
the most amount of money,
and you have to hire quickly
and you have to scale really quickly.
And what I'd love to spend
the last few minutes
is talk to me a little bit about
your perspective on this fresh, young,
entrepreneurial experience,
and what myself and my friends
can take away moving forward
as we begin our entrepreneurial journey
at the end, to make an impact?
What are some key things
that we should be keeping in mind
and some key pieces of advice
that you've accumulated over the years?
Well, I think the sense of pressure
on oneself has pros and cons, I mean,
the truth is
it is a very competitive world.
If you want to be successful
in anything that you do,
it would seem to be obvious
when you look at other successful people
that hard work is required
and that a lot of people
try to be successful but can't.
And so, and especially in fields
like entrepreneurship
and venture capital,
it requires a ton of work
and a lot of luck, I think,
to achieve any modicum of success.
So, it's rational to feel some stress
about that.
At the same time, of course,
you don't want to let the stress
and anxiety and the fear be debilitating.
And it's useful, I think, to cultivate
a spiritual practice
or to codify a set of personal values
or to remember the bigger picture
about what matters in life
with regards to relationships and family
and things like that,
so as to not be totally overtaken
by the stress involved with
one's career ambitions.
I'd say with respect
to the sort of things to keep in mind,
I think the best decisions
that I've ever made
and the worst decisions
I've ever made
have had to do with people
and judgement of people.
And so, probably
the single best meta-skill to develop,
or one of the best meta-skills,
because I could think of some others
as I say this,
such as how to learn.
But a meta-skill for this conversation
that comes to mind Michael,
is being really good at evaluating people
and understanding whether
you want someone in your tribe,
whether you want someone
working at your company,
whether it's somebody
you want to work for.
And just calibrating your sense of,
how do people present themselves,
what are the sorts
of things I'm looking for,
when is someone trying to deceive me,
when is someone deceiving themselves.
And then they lack self-awareness about
their strengths and weaknesses, etc.
People are enormously complicated.
They're also fascinating.
To get really good at
understanding the psychology of people,
is a generalizable skill that I think
will be helpful in any number
of career paths.
100%.
One of the things that I have got
and expose myself over the past
year and a half or so
has been
how many opportunities there are.
And people that are
curious about especially engineering.
And you're investing primarily
in software and in IT solutions.
And the number of opportunities
are just endless.
And the ways in which
we can really improve the world
is just phenomenal.
And for me as a young entrepreneur,
what I get most excited about
is just thinking of all the different
things we can do that can make
a huge, huge impact,
which is why I just love the way
that you're talking about the zigzagging,
This lifelong entrepreneurial journey,
it's not just about
what you're working on now.
It's about how you're approaching
every problem with the potential solution
and motivating others along the way.
Because I'm sure that just by having
that mindset in yourself,
every person that comes
that interacts with Ben
gets that motivation as well.
So, thank you for being inspiration
for me and for whoever else
who is watching this.
Before we go, I really want to thank you
for being generous with your time.
And the hardest question, three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Three words that come to mind,
the first obvious, entrepreneurial,
the second curious.
I have a lot of different interests.
I'm curious about things.
And the third would be reflective.
I tend to reflect a lot on my life
and the world around me,
and for better or for worse,
reflective would be my third choice.
It's very counterintuitive
to see someone who is so driven,
who has done so much,
and then say that they're,
one of the words
that a best describes them is reflective,
which often has a connotation
of sitting back, taking a moment,
breathing and thinking through
what they're feeling.
So, I highly appreciate that.
Ben, thank you very much.
Stay safe and stay healthy
during these crazy times.
And I hope to meet in person
back in the Silicon Valley.
Thank you, Michael.
Thanks for having me.